das wiederum könnte wenn jemand zu neuen
ufern aufbricht und andere mitnehmen
will brachte er einen starken willen
besonders wenn die ufer fernsicht und
über das ziel
keine einigkeit herrscht von einer
solchen reise handelt dieser film
dieser mercedes fährt mit benzin
dieses flugzeug fliegt mit kerosin und
die passagierin wurde bis vor kurzem der
atomlobby zu gerechnet doch jetzt heißt
ihre mission energiewende
am ende ist
doris leuthard will sonne und wind statt
drei neue atomkraftwerke für die schweiz
ihre gegner sprechen von planwirtschaft
und kosten für die konsumenten von
dutzenden von milliarden
die kehrtwende der bundesrätin kam nach
fukushima an internationalen konferenzen
versucht sie die schweiz im europäischen
strommarkt zu vernetzen
bisher haben die stimmbürger einen
ausstieg aus der kernkraft immer
abgelehnt und noch 2008 sagte der
bundesrat
ohne neue atomkraftwerke gehe es nicht
jetzt sagt doris leuthard man könne
gegen die neue strategie hat das
referendum ergreifen
und so reist sie von ort zu ort um zu
erklären wie es trotzdem gehen könnte an
einem regentag in bern weit sie der
neuen schule und erlebnis zug der sbb
ein
im zug sollen die jugendlichen einen
sparsamen umgang mit energie lernen ein
teil der energiestrategie 2050 unsere
zukunft
was schon für erwachsene schwierig zu
verstehen ist will die bundesrätin hirt
den jugendlichen näher bringen das alter
fordert der treibstoff dass fossile
energie integriert ersetze durch
erneuerbare der schwarze darauf solar
wind oder biomasse
da geht es heute nicht einfach nicht
leisten sich die unachtsam also
inklusive und der wettermann einer
möglichst produzieren und nicht nur
importieren und das alles will mit am
schluss seines ziel hat kann
was das gefühl mich raus kommen am
meisten energie machen die zukunft
mitzunehmen
das ist sicher ein wichtiger teil aber
[Gelächter]
was allerdings das thema ist das viel
übersetzt wie viel sonnenenergie das
sind auch wie viel dass man also noch
nicht viel vom trainer gibt es nun schon
her dass ohne gimmicks wie vor sind es
dann jetzt jetzt jemand ist
wahrscheinlich 0,15 prozent genau darum
haben das große potenzial jedes jahr
um eine maschine wäsche zu waschen
müsste diese gruppe eine stunde lang
kurbeln
doch nach einer guten minute sind alle
erschöpft
ich war wirklich mehr mut zeigen sich
nicht nur sony fliesst geht's caprice
aber es hat sich mit langem für den
krieg kann sich jetzt vorstellt dass
hinzu muss betriebe müssten doch ganz
einfach aber da müssen wir vorher reiter
ganze ventilator und radio und
vielleicht auch dass uns gott gar nicht
weiß wer besuch im norden viel ändern
ja wir sind einfach der grösste
energieverbraucher in der schweiz und
sein solo es schon heute dass handel uns
zum ziel gesetzt wenn wir nach zwei
anspruchsvolle ziel setzt da wieder
bewegung
diese reise gehe er in die falsche
richtung sagt die physikerin ihren
agatha sie ist vizepräsidentin der
akademien der technischen wissenschaften
und gründerin des vereins frauen in der
nuklearphysiker und den klimawandel zu
bewältigen brauche es die atomkraft weil
sie praktisch co2 frei sei
schon als junges mädchen posierte sie in
abstimmungskämpfen mit ihrem foto heinz
weihnachts die hanne frauen für energie
gründet und imperien 80 haben wir ja
eine energieart ständig nach dem
aufstiegsrennen
also erstens und war gerührt ich der
muss mehr für gesicht verrät die
stromversorgung uns aber der wahl mit
eurer position
ich bin nicht sich ihre miene und einer
wir jetzt plötzlich vor der lügt sind
gemäss neusten umfragen aber einig mit
lukas einlenken
man muss er nicht unbedingt soll ihr
baby physikalisch sei der ausstieg aus
der atomkraft unrealistisch und man
vergesse dass die energiewende für die
natur auch ihre schattenseiten habe
durch zu 800 große kraftwerk wo wenn sie
die hersteller das ist alan joyce schutz
das ist eben
die physikerin betreibt einen
internetblog der eine alte schlagzeile
über den wahlkampf von doris leuthard
auf die schippe nimmt
am forum der internationalen
energieproduzenten werden die
zukünftigen entwicklungen diskutiert das
hauptthema ist der ungebremste anstieg
des co2 der grund der hunger der
weltwirtschaft nach günstiger fossiler
energie davon importiert die schweiz
einen teil ein ende ist nicht abzusehen
spektakuläres wachstum lang nicht ums
wachstum zwischen ihren acker tor stört
das in der schweiz an stelle der kws
gaskraftwerke geplant sind
in deutschland sehe man bereits dass
neben sonne und wind vermehrt fossile
energien verbraucht würden
das verfahren in deutschland messen
schaffte quante und darf denn das muss
mit bedeutet wirklich an alter stelle
umso wichtiger sei es nach alternativen
zu suchen sagt bundesrätin doris
leuthards mit einem pilotprojekt
versucht sie das im logistikzentrum der
migros in neuendorf auch an diesem tag
regnet es in strömen
wenn wind und sonne fehlen woher kommt
die energie wie könnte man sie speichern
wir sind an dem standort ein großer
energie bezüge mit 26 millionen
kilowattstunden sind ungefähr halb durch
das heißt die stadt wo man an einem
standort allein sind und was vor allem
wichtig ist zwei drittel davon in
schweigen
das ist ein starker strompreise vor
allem das tiefkühllager der micro ist so
etwas wie der grösste kühlschrank der
schweiz könnte dieser vielleicht als
stromspeicher dienen
unter der leitung des bundesamts für
energie wird das getestet
[Musik]
das
was hat es die verlage umrisse stimmt -
8 21 grad ist relativ frisch mit dem
ausstieg aus der atomenergie mit durch
die energie aber nicht nur im
wärmebereich sondern ein kälte würde ich
von dem rechten rad nicht so aber wenn
man doch natürlich energie aber fahre
werden dass sie gebraucht wenn es hier
mal gerade die 20 oder 21 punkten hielt
war natürlich für die enorme menge strom
wo man sparen
prinzipiell sei das machbar lautet das
wissen tat ein jahr später die realen
hürden blieben aber hoch und das
sparpotenzial begrenzt auf dem dach des
tiefkühl lagers lässt sich die
bundesrätin für ein magazin
fotografieren
hier steht später die größte
photovoltaik-anlage der schweiz
resultat ist stolz denn damit können
1300 haushalte mit strom versorgt werden
wenn die sonne scheint
das tönt nach viel doch wenn hier ein
tonnen schwerer güterzug losfährt bracht
er alleine etwa die doppelte menge
wo liegen die grenzen der energiewende
acht gewählt
der renault wir stufen und darum glaube
ich es auch alte frankfurter team ich
habe hier immer zwingend muss ein
verstörendes über gebäude förderprogramm
ich habe eine photovoltaikanlage sowie
da und ich habe sowieso schon praktisch
und gut isoliert kiefernstraße da es
eben vorher über beruflich bedingte wand
bundesrats mercedes sowie ökonomie
warum ich bei woche ist der
energie-effizienz sich aber sicher mehr
an vorgaben vom vbs muss mercedes oder
audi limousinen also wie auch das sehen
wir sich an einem vorbild habe ich dank
der weg ist das ziel ist so schön heißt
und manche profitorientierung und wenn
man nur sich das ziel setzen das nicht
knacken
unterdessen fährt doris leuthard ein
elektromobil
die physikerin ihre neckartor und ihr
mann tun das schon länger gleich zwei
umweltfreundliche fahrzeuge stehen in
der garage
[Musik]
das herrschaftliche haus hoch über dem
zürichsee ist im minergiestandard gebaut
wärmepumpenheizung es
ihre in agatha und ihrem mann ebenfalls
ein physiker haben freunde aus der
nuklearindustrie eingeladen um einen
film zu diskutieren
der in amerika für kontroversen sorgt
in pandoras promis erklären umwelt und
klimaschützer warum sie ihre meinung zur
atomenergie geändert haben
trotz ungelöster fragen sei es über
alles betrachtet die beste alternative
zu den fossilen energien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber ist dieser zug nicht längst
abgefahren
aber wir diskutieren mit analytischer
jahrzehnt der schulqualität und das
problem nach fukushima sei die angst vor
der atomkraft verständlich gewesen weil
man zu wenig über das unglück wusste
doch radioaktivität sei beherrschbar
[Musik]
heute zeige sich dass fukushima kein
argument sei um aus der atomenergie
auszusteigen meint tatsächlich meldete
die presse zwei jahre nach dem unglück
dass die erste umfassende untersuchung
der uno durch 180 wissenschaftler
ergeben habe dass weder menschen starben
noch vermehrt an krebs
erkranken würden
einen schnellen ausstieg aus der
kernkraft vollzieht die schweiz nicht
denn solange sie sicher sind sollen die
lkws weiterlaufen
wir sagen danke an drehte sich mit bau
ist mit der heutigen technologie
ich habe eine verbotene 29 oder aber
verboten sind ausnahmebewilligung immer
man geht aber wir haben dem x1
durchbruch geschafft
der strom ist
das nicht aus bis jetzt der rückstand
und brachte einen knall
das tangiert
kritik wird sich das die richtige
entscheidung
wir haben die große chance frauen wenig
jahren wirklich alle staaten und der
waadt lösung ist volkswirtschaftlich
wichtige züchter und erneuerbare wenn
wir die eigentlich bis haltestelle
spanien doris leuthards reise gleicht
jener von deutschland dort wurden wind-
und sonnenenergie stark subventioniert
jetzt gibt es viel billigen strom auf
dem markt weil er europäisch gehandelt
wird kommt die schweiz erneut unter die
räder
saubere wasserkraft als den schweizer
bergen ist jetzt nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig rentiert nicht mehr
europa möchte die negativen folgen durch
mehr zusammenarbeit vermeiden
alleingänge wie derjenige von
deutschland belasten die netze die
gefahren von black als steigen
deutschland hat hier enorm hohe summen
eingesetzt
finde mehr alle übertrieben auch die
dauer aber das ist auch ein prozess und
wir müssen nicht dieselben systeme
kopieren wie deutschland aber ein
eigenes service ist weiter als den
deutschen greifen central european damit
die schweiz mithalten kann will doris
leuthard die einheimische wasserkraft
mit 600 millionen franken
subventionieren
vier jahre nach fukushima bleibt der
umstrittene weg der bundesrätin zu neuen
ufern steinig doris leuthard aber ist
immer noch voller energie